he's the founder of Swedish
high-performance car manufacturer
Koenigsegg automotive he showed
interesting cars from an early age at
six years old he drove a go-kart for the
first time in his life he created the
world's fastest road car which can go
from zero to four hundred kilometers an
hour in just under 20 seconds he's
Christian von Koenigsegg and here are
his top ten rules for success in only 21
years cunning Zack has come from nowhere
to be one of the highest regarded hyper
car manufacturers being counted
alongside Ferrari Lamborghini and
McLaren how have they pulled that off
well we had to work hard be a little bit
innovative and don't believe in the hype
that it's impossible but it's you know
every day we we strive and push and and
learn and adapt and when you do that for
20 years with a great focus within the
group you can do pretty much anything I
think that's the simple answer but for
sure it's not easy you have to be
prepared to work hard for it
from a personal perspective up my
ambition is always been to build cars
that's why I started my company at 22
years of age 15 16 years ago
and that's all I've been doing since
then and then this opportunity presented
itself
to be able to build cars a little bit
larger scale with a brand that was very
dear to me and we jumped on this
opportunity and here we are today so the
Koenigsegg group we consists of all
entrepreneurs and if you look at all our
track records whatever we started we
still have
and continue with and work with to make
it prosper and we have the same ambition
with Saab
we have gotten into this because we want
to live with solve and work with Saab
for a very long period of time it's not
something we do short-term it's a
long-term ambition and basically we
don't do it because it's easy we do it
because it's a challenge it's a real
challenge and it's a worthwhile
challenge where we can make a difference
well as I mentioned I have this I saw
this Norwegian movie when I was about
five years old and got this guy who
built the really interesting sports car
and I remember saying to myself that
when I grew up that's what I want to do
as well I want to build my own car cars
and seldom saw that dream never left me
so when I was 19 I started my first
company which was a trading company to
make little bit money with the ambition
to use that money to build my own cars
and I went when I was 22 I had made a
little bit of money and then I started
the car company and that was in 1994
which was 18 years ago
Koenigsegg are fully independent and
manufacture their cars entirely in-house
we ask that this independence is a
benefit to them I do I do for example
with the rig era I don't see any of the
other established super hyper car brands
daring to remove shifting of gears it's
such a fundamental thing to take away
from a sports car that I think it's only
quranic' say that could make that
decision
and I'm very confident about the
decision I'm very confident when people
experience that direct power that
instant control you get and directness
that that they will quickly understand
why that's a very good alternative to
shifting even though shifting is fun
nice and part of driving a sports car so
so for example yeah we have more
freedoms like that or take more freedoms
like that of course we want to infuse
some with with spirit and and and kind
of make people really look forward to go
to work and they can they feel that they
can make a difference it's basically
about empowering people solve this from
the chemxtech perspective from mechanics
is super part company perspective a very
large company but still it's its people
and they're developing cars on a larger
scale so we still think we can get that
kind of family feeling going but it's
mostly important to empower people to
know they can make a difference and
really work together I see that the
company is important my family I guess I
see our cars like my children
two suns gel a very very very much but
also the cars are my baby somehow I
really care a lot about them and it's
like a part of myself
somehow I don't I don't separate my own
being from the company or the cars who
are really connected together it's my
life I don't see my work as work
I don't see who I am what I do I think
it's one of our strengths I mean there
are strengths of being a big corporation
would all the resources you have at hand
but there are also strengths for a small
founder driven sports car company that
we have to utilize to compensate for the
lack of size so of course we heard that
all the big brands in the industry we're
creating their next level super hyper
car hybrid cars and we were not sure
what they were coming out with we were
assuming they want to trump our car the
Pagani the Bugatti in every aspect and
at simultaneously we started developing
the one-to-one program so we we want to
make sure we overshot what we already
did by quite a margin and maybe we we
brought it a little bit higher than we
needed to we will see but I think it
will compare quite favorably to these
new hybrid hyper cars
buttburn when it comes to us competing
with the big boys I think that's what
we've always been doing so that's
nothing new it's really a David against
Goliath kind of scenario that we're
pretty used to and and are fine with and
and enjoy at the same time I would say
so the motivation to create the one to
one even though we already had a
superbly fast car that also was good for
track use was that some of our customers
really wanted a more of a cup car GT car
just specifically developed for the
track but they also came with a demand
that you should have full road usability
and full homologation and that was a big
bit of a challenge because what we ended
up building was more or less a car that
looks and feels like a GT one car on the
track but then you push a button
raises up and you have all the creature
comforts air conditioning satellite
navigation Bluetooth telephone air
conditioning whatever that our normal
cars have but we have to say wait and we
had to have more downforce we had to
have a stiffer chassis setting when
needed on the track and also lighter
weight so yeah that was that was the
motivation and that was the challenge
well I remember when I started that
first of all there were many examples of
people starting car companies extreme
corners I'm not succeeding doing it for
different races and I remember saying to
myself I have to start when I'm young
which is going to be very difficult it's
going to take very long time
that I'm determined to do it even if
it's almost impossible and I expect that
I was coming from Sweden only 22 years
old I expected everyone to say maybe not
crazy my life is impossible you will
never succeed against agreement so I
expected that so when I got that
response it did not push me down because
I was ready for that medicinals I kind
of Miss that triggered me even more to
say yes I understand that you think that
but I will show you that it is actually
possible I get a lot of now feedback
from people around to see this who are
doing other things in other areas not
only card but I say since you could do
that it anything must be possible so you
made me believe in my dream and now I've
done this and succeeded and kind of
thank you whatever and that is so great
because it actually proves that even
hypercars can be very beneficial to
society because it shows dreams are
possible
so
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because mo potty Bo got
sue asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the top
10 tips' met the most to you leave in
the comments I'm going to join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon